I recently played the latest
installments of life is strange tales
from the borderlands and dreamfall
chapters now these are all episodic
games but they've been some of my most
enjoyable and anticipated experiences
this year but is the episodic model
actually any good now we shouldn't have
any false illusions about this episodic
games are really only around because it
works extraordinarily well for
publishers with the high cost of game
production the episodic model is a good
way for publishers to make money to help
fund continual and future development
it's a faster more condensed cycle the
sales from one episode enabled them to
keep making the content they have
planned more comfortably the publisher
also gets the advantages of player
feedback time to implement that feedback
more money to support additional
development time and more prolonged
consumer interest than they ordinarily
would get if they did it in one big go
they eventually get a full game package
out and everybody goes home happy right
well yes and no but the audience it
comes down to what you personally value
in games but first let's take a look at
how the episodic model has changed to
become what it is today the beginnings
of episodic game content had clear
aspirations to mimic the way TV shows
are distributed what's interesting is
the kind of media they wanted to mimic
changing over time and how that affected
the overall format telltale Games's
early titles paint a pretty clear
picture of how the episodic gaming model
used to be handled Ricardo Sanchez who
was the VP of one of Telltale's
distributors at the time gametap once
said he had three rules for episodic
content the episodes must be short
standalone and delivered regularly and
within a defined period of time series
such as waltz and grommets grand
adventures strong Bad's cool game for
attractive people and three seasons of
salmon max were all made with this
philosophy telltale wore their TV
influences on their sleeve as well by
making four seasons of CSI adventure
James and even one based on Lauren order
before they started moving into
serialized film based stories with back
to the future and Jurassic Park you can
probably see where I'm going with this
that standalone episodes philosophies
was replaced by games could feature one
major mainline narrative serialized into
several episodes czo present-day
telltale adventures like tales from the
borderlands and the wolf among us as
well as games like life is strange
Resident Evil Revelations 2 and any
other episodic game you can think of
that keeps the story rolling forward
even though they may sometimes opt to
alter character perspectives or forego
linear time once in a while the fact the
telltale are now making games based off
the Walking Dead and Game of Thrones is
a pretty good indication of the
different style of television approach
they're taking now it's about wanting to
find out what comes next in the big
season long story so one of the general
pros and cons although publishers having
more time and money to create the
individual segments as they go is a huge
plus the benefits to using this model
don't stop there
publishers are also able to take
advantage of having several release
dates for each individual episode to
yell about on the internet that extends
the marketing period and prolongs
consumer interests or at least awareness
and should a whole season of episodes be
received positively it lends itself to
the creation of subsequent seasons
Walking Dead Season 3 is a sure thing
for instance so yay for the publishers
but what about us would I rather have
the entirety of dreamful chapters to
play through at my leisure sure but all
those benefits for the publisher really
do end up ultimately benefiting the
gamer as well let's use dreamfall
chapters as an example red thread games
had a successful Kickstarter which
launched with the intent of creating
dreamfall chapters as a full game the
time to produce the game on top of
additional development demands of
meeting Kickstarter stretch goals would
have meant that waiting for the whole
game was going to take years because of
that it ultimately worked out better for
red thread to release the game in
segments since you know we actually get
to play it now
creative director regnal tourist
explained as a time quote we've also
realized that while as a small studio we
are capable of producing a massively
ambitious game like dreamfall chapters
we're not satisfied with our ability to
properly finish polish and bug fix the
whole game in one go by releasing book 1
we hope to start generating income all
of which will go right back into
improving the quality and scope of
subsequent books so in addition to
getting a bit of the game sooner we'll
hopefully receive a better game than we
would have if it it all come out in one
go episodic games can be attractive to
consumers for more intangible benefits -
like if you don't have much time to
commit to gaming and want a story based
game you can enjoy for a couple of hours
or if you like the idea of being able to
buy the first episode of a game and see
if you actually like it before
committing to buying the whole season of
course those advantages also bring
disadvantages the big one is ambiguous
release dates rarely do episodic games
have predetermined - release dates
anymore since they're increasing in
scope and the next episode is usually
being developed as you're playing the
current one like in the case of
dreamfall chapters Resident Evil
Revelations 2 worked quite differently
as Capcom essentially had it all
finished before its first episode was
out but this is certainly the exception
and not the rule
sometimes subsequent episodes have
pushed back and sometimes like in the
case of Sonic the Hedgehog for the first
two episodes just didn't get the
reception the publisher wanted and no
more were produced personally I'm a big
fan of the episodic model because the
caters towards the kind of games that I
love to play that it won't work for
everything and that's okay that said it
is a good way for smaller devs to be
able to slowly but surely build out big
ideas and pull in an audience along the
way
but that's just my opinion so be sure to
head down to that comment section and
let me know if you think it's a good
development and distribution model and
why or why not